[Musique]
on l'arrête dans la rue en peu de temps
hubert le noir est devenu une vedette
spéciale se gavant j'étais juste connu
auprès des gens que j'aimais ma musique
sénat je sens que je suis connue par des
gens qui m'aiment aussi que même poste
[Musique]
originaire de beauport à québec hubert
le noir de son vrai nom hubert chiasson
a commencé sa carrière musicale à l'âge
de 17 ans avec son groupe the seasons
[Musique]
total en france au talent et à berlin où
dallas los angeles on ne s'avoue fait de
pouvoir le monde
puis il ya eu la transformation lui qui
aime depuis l'adolescence les vêtements
pour femmes et le maquillage s'assume de
plus en plus mon but j'ai juste portée
que je veux ce pauvre guy personnes
quand je provoque et j'avais provoquer
mais équipe avec mon l'autre des foyers
dont ils disent nous on n'a rien inventé
c'est bon tu dors je faisais ceux des
villes wifi jamais dit que j'allais vous
ratez rien de monsieur je vous proposais
la musique je m'habille demain un goût
pour les induire les gens ce que
j'évoquais sur son premier album solo
l'artiste de 23 ans parle de liberté
d'émancipation de la femme et c'est
voulu
je suis féministe je pense que je dis
sexualité passagers papa de les opinions
suffit ministre mais mais je peux pas
laisser ça prend trop de place parce que
je pense que c'est quand même drôle dit
les femmes de parler
d'ailleurs c'est grâce en partie à une
femme qu'il connaît le succès son
amoureuse non il me leclerc a financé
près de la moitié de l'album intitulé
darlene en travaillant dans une chaîne
de restauration rapide mais avec le
succès sont aussi venus les réactions
sur les réseaux sociaux on s'en est pris
à lui et son passage à l'émission la
voix il a répliqué en disant aux
homophobes
je vous emmerde tous moi je me fais
crier des noms depuis toujours quand je
me promène sur le thé sur la rue effecté
j'étais vraiment confiant quant à
l'avant 2.6 millions de personnes les
mêmes personnes qui dans russie sa
lettre lehmann qui allait me permets
même le crier des noms mais le par
l'entremise des réseaux sociaux c'est
pas que c'est seulement ça ça ma vraie
argué fait
les jours se suivent sont
sacré révélation radio-canada 2018 2019
hubert lenoir n'a pas fini de faire
parler de lui son deuxième album est en
chantier et il a plusieurs projets en
tête
je travaille ensemble sur un projet
d'art performance qui vous tue voit le
jour bientôt le stand bonne idée que je
peux la doivent à sinon j'ai pas comme
la folle qui est la face avant moi parce
que prétend la loi ils se rassurent ce
sinon tu as aussi sur la musique de film
qui veut groupe entend dire le nom
[Musique]
ici louis fils klimek radio 15 à
montréal ici
[Musique]